ooh wall with glass he stopped us
[Music]
Salam alaikum you and me
which the noise in the door Pacho might
be a bit more of a challenge
where's that policeman look at this
surreal scene
morning guys here in Karachi but not for
long
going out to the coast godori
right good re Granada Kidani Kidani one
of the world's biggest ship breaking
yards up to 1 million tonnes my metal
has got to hear from this place and it's
not done through machines it's done
through human muscle sweat and probably
tears so let's go on this adventure and
check out this very fascinating place
[Music]
stuck in traffic cross the line from
crotchy into Balochistan right yeah all
right well let's just end right now so a
lot of security forces out a lot of
Rangers and policemen
[Music]
now when they come okay guys starting to
get interesting
saw a few boats from the car on the road
and then there's one out here quite a
huge tanker what is it the are steam oh
I believe it's called so legend has it
in 1960 a big cyclone took place in the
Arabian Sea and washed up a large wooden
boat here and the locals dismantled it
salvaged it sold the parts and then the
opportunity was seen the locals saw they
could salvage boats here sell the raw
materials in Karachi
make a living and so this whole beach is
about 10 kilometers roughly 135
different plots of beach for salvaging
boats
look there's any snakes here in
Balochistan
getting here was quite interesting it my
driver said some of the nature
neighborhoods on the edges of Crouch
were very dangerous
and then when we got into Balochistan
there's a different feel huge huge
Ranger presence if you're not familiar
with the Rangers there's sort of like
I'd say military police I don't think
it's the army it's like a separate
separate branch ok getting closer to
their steam oh you can see the scraps
over there I think you can see it in the
GoPro in the distance a lot of scrap
metal here it's crazy to think what was
it 1 million tons of metal come out of
this place so let's get into let's
investigate what the story is here ooh
wall with glass and a ravine ok might be
a bit more of a challenge than
originally thought so wall with glass up
there and a bit of a [ __ ] thorn up my
shoe look at that
second there's a knife in the bottom of
my foot okay there are a few barriers to
entry here mega thorns dried-out moat
broken glass on the wall so tread
carefully and resume the mission hey
guys were on more of an adventure than I
first thought
for some reason I thought it would be
easy to just sort of get up onto the
beach you see them doing the work it's
not cool it makes it more interesting
okay this is like uh seems like a road
for the workers to walk to work it's not
that fresh seaside smell you might
imagine
smells like well I'm sure ecologically
this isn't the best thing that can
happen for these beaches Wow look at
that massive tanker looks like the front
the front was taken apart and they got a
lot of work left look all this machinery
on the beach Wow and to see the sea
looks quite beautiful and it actually
looks blue turquoise here we have
another boat waiting to get pulled apart
Wow moments like these guys this is what
I love about travel just the discovery
and the randomness and the surreal nests
of situations like these speech is
actually quite nice and I'm surprised
there's no litter on it Wow
first goal is to get into one of these
ships and see the process second goal
find an English speaker that might be a
little challenging and the third and
probably the most important goal is
don't get kicked out like so many of the
things so many of the videos I do it's
do first and then wait for the no don't
ask because when you ask for things like
this usually it draws a bizarre
attention
there's a guy yelling up there look at
this surreal scene oh my god
absolutely stunning these colors two
guys coming behind me
just really want to get this shot
because how cool is that
safe but now
the fish
Salam alaikum
sir can I get in there in the ship
you and me
can we go through the door
no I look okay
salamualikum'
sir and I ain't but can I go inside huh
can we go inside exit we go inside
just gonna follow get into this thing
okay it's dark in here this is what the
inside of an oil tanker looks like Wow
before oil Lada echo
they're arguing over I should be in here
or not
ah-choo what's the notice what what
workers up there
Salam alaikum
Salam alaikum sir we go in the door
in German engine
oh they go up the ladder there
the goal is to get up to get up the
ladder and I got one guy not allowing so
all the workers were excited they wanted
to they were cool of taking me up that
ladder to get into the ship
but there's one security guy there
wasn't having it so I managed to let
them let me ask the boss and the boss is
up in this building the white building
and so that's where we're at
asking the boss and I'm gonna put the
camera down because getting a lot of
stares
I'm gonna keep it up I'm gonna keep it
up all right
Salam alaikum
[Music]
a lot of friendly workers quite a
surreal scene don't know if you're
feeling it on the camera but definitely
a first
Salam alaikum
and see all these parts just sectioned
off sold to the markets I'm guessing all
this goes to Karachi where's the
policeman so the policeman says I have
to leave it and what about the driver
he's fine he's going to find the driver
right now
in the offices and very nice guys gave
me tea but then the security guard came
back he said I need permits to be in
Balochistan which I don't have when I
wasn't told I needed so he's on the
phone I'm trying I really want to really
put your heart had the guys ready
he stopped us there massive engines
[Applause]
what's that attempt number one failed
their 140 134 of these lots though so
the goal is to get on to another ship
very nice people in they're very
accommodating it's just the police shut
it down well I think you could see
behind me the homes where the workers
live in so they all work on the ships
there on the beach and then they they
live there too so it seems like its own
ecosystem unbelievable though with all
those parts all that different machinery
there's so much that goes into making a
ship and taking it apart obviously
all right back to the driver and then
try to figure out another plan here I
came out of the shipyard
to my driver and the police were there
with him saying they gotta bring me out
of here ASAP right now and nobody gets
in trouble so that was that guys that
was a little flirtation with the ship
deconstruction in Balochistan Pakistan
until next one
and the third and probably the most
important goal is don't get kicked out